news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
all right welcome back to the program
we're taking calls today via discord for
the first time
and i have to tell you davidpakman.com
discord it really
has improved audio quality dramatically
we're continuing our
tour of the world next we are going to
go to mikko from
finland i love finland i had the
pleasure of being there
last year it was an amazing experience
mikko where in finland are you and
what's on your mind today
hi david it's uh uh
it's dark here and it's cold and uh on
my mind it is
that the your country seems to be on the
words of civil war
and at the end of democracy
yes very clear your assessment from
finland
is accurate thank you
now what do you think
if things do get violent and do get out
of hand and
fall into anarchy what good pointers
could you give
to people to do on how to react
and what to do if the anarchy breaks out
i don't know the answer to that you know
i i have friends on the left who never
considered getting firearms before
who were never preppers who now have
firearms
they are very very scared about the
possibility for violence i
i don't know what to advise people to do
my my hope is that
state national guards are not going to
allow
violence incited by donald trump to take
over states
i cannot imagine you know we have a
republican governor here in
massachusetts charlie baker
despite being a republican charlie baker
refused to send any national guard down
to the border when donald trump wanted
to use the national guard down there
my belief is if it really came to it and
i hope it doesn't that charlie baker is
going to use the state national guard
uh to protect against the violence that
donald trump may be
wanting to incite but i am as much in in
the dark
metaphorically miko as you were saying
finland is in the dark uh from the
standpoint of light because
i don't know what's going to happen okay
thank you that's very good
answer uh then another word that i
have found that is very descriptive of
your country
at the moment is kakistocracy kakistakis
yes yes which which i think
that is uh well means
that the country is governed by the
least qualified
do you agree uh it's it's hard to find
people less qualified than trump yeah i
mean i was thinking
you know i think back to my college
professors earlier this week i
interviewed richard wolff okay richard
wolff is a socialist a lot of people
aren't socialists
richard wolff would have handled the
pandemic better than donald trump i
think back to
i ran into a high school english teacher
over the weekend my high school english
teacher
dropped in to deal with coronavirus
would have handled it better than donald
trump merely by deferring to experts
it's hard to imagine short of someone
who is truly cognitively disabled
straight up disabled of people that
would be worse suited to be in charge
right now you're absolutely correct
i'm so sorry that it is come to this
yeah hope the next hope for the next one
yeah mikko listen what what part of uh
what part of finland are you in i'm
about one hour
drive away from helsinki downtown and
it's
a little bit over one hour by car and um
we're very southern part well i love
helsinki there's this uh are you
familiar with this
salmon soup that is very typical of
helsinki
yes i am where cinnamon soup is actually
very typical of
all of finland what a what a dish what a
delightful dish i just had i must have
had that 10 times when i was in finland
absolutely delicious
nice to hear yeah uh all right mikko i
appreciate you calling in and i hope to
be back in finland before too long
okay we'll come all right there it is
mikko
what a friendly guy people are just so
friendly in uh
in finland